so we're going to get started here with
Sandy in Cleveland Ohio sandy you're on
the Dave Ramsey show how can we help hi
hi can Rachel Chris Chris
congratulations on retired inspired it's
an excellent book well thank you very
very much
hello I'm 29 years old I was divorced in
2013 and one of them is there was many
issues money being one of the major ones
my husband really wasn't financially
savvy and was not a great accountability
partner and kind of gave me some
insecurity issues with money now I'm
currently seeing another guy that we've
been together for two years it's like
great he believes in cash is king
principle pay always pays in cash always
has a hundred $200 to $1,000 on hand I
disclose my financials he listens to me
I still find myself though without an
accountability partner and also I'm
trying to kind of vet him for like
possible marriage potential however he's
unwilling to disclose any financial uh
he claims he once had a business that he
receives an annuity that he invest
though I've never seen any proof and
sometimes it seems like he could be over
exaggerating but I don't want to be
blindsided should I get into this more
in a permanent statute later I've read
all your books like money makeover start
retired and fired looking for guidance
and inspiration but I just don't know
how I can have an accountability partner
and also to kind of at him for possibly
making him my husband yeah well sandy I
can tell you hon I think with with
heaven the experience that you've had in
the past what you walk through gives you
validation and wanting to make sure that
we don't repeat the same issues and and
I think you're dead on to be able to
want to know and have this discussion
now here's the key is this going to be
someone you're dating or is he truly
marriage potential and I think that's
something that he's going to decide in
his actions
because the one thing you don't want to
do sandy is to marry this guy as he is
now expecting him to change after he
says I do when people get married you're
accepting accepting them for as they are
right now
so I think you haven't walked through
what you did in 2013 you have every
right to want to have this opportunity
to have conversation and for him to be
able to open up and talk with you if
he's not then he's telling you he's not
willing to work together on the money
stuff and that to me I would tell you to
caution and guard your heart and be very
careful about how much you're sharing
and the information you're doing you may
need to go find a better accountability
partner and let this person remain a
friend yeah when it comes to
accountability partner 2 is since you
guys are dating out recommend finding a
girlfriend that you can talk to about
this
I mean sure your boyfriend would be
wonderful but since he's not able to
find someone then that you can talk to
about this but the fact that you can't
talk to your boyfriend and you're
thinking about marriage potential yeah
that obviously gives definitely a red
flag and here's the thing to know you
said something you said he's not able to
no no he's unwilling you know yeah yeah
he's not willing to yes and for I would
be curious ask her though is is he
unwilling to because maybe it is a large
sum and he's nervous on his own hey is
she you know is it that or is it that
it's over-exaggeration whatever it is
but I'm like if you can't trust someone
with one you can't trust them to get
married I mean if you're if you're
unable to open up about that and again
it depends on their situation you know
what's happening with them in the
stating relationship but for dating
couples out there remember keep your
finances separate and when marriage
starts getting into the picture you need
to talk about it that's a key point it
may just be that he's not that into her
yet no it cooks very possible I said I
know his business I'm just yeah he got a
ton of money and he's a little scared of
hey what if she knows she realizes and
you know what I mean I don't know maybe
he's not there yet as well and here's
the deal if he's not there she can't
make him be there that's my and if he's
unwilling that he's unwilling but she
needs to acknowledge that upfront acts
and then that way she can treat it
accordingly because if he's just going
to be a good friend then let's treat him
like a good friend instead of a
potential husband I'm telling you it
could be an indicator that he's not
ready to have that conversation you got
to be realistic and it's a great
indicator Chris great point
sandy thank you so much for the call hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
you are not a victim you're not a victim
of big corporations you're not a victim
of Wall Street you're not a victim of
capitalism you're not a victim of wealth
inequality you're not a victim of racism
you're not a victim